you really bought the party that was a
fun performance well thank you man it
was awesome I was so nervous Lanny
Wilson is one of the best singers I know
she never misses a note I always miss
notes so it's every time you sitting
next to her my butt cheeks are clenched
that's cool you're just sweating you're
like okay we gotta get through this and
that was emotional too man it was you
know it was really sad watching Colin go
off right before we went on I've just
fell in love with Colin I fell in love
with all of them so you know it's just
so hard man it's like you're damn you
can't win you know there's going to be a
winner tonight everybody wins tonight
but just so hard to watch two of them to
go but you know what the exposure alone
I mean this is a huge opportunity for
these artists and you know the the grind
you know you know when I told him I said
what y'all don't know is none of y'all
will be working for gas money next week
you know what I'm saying they all don't
know this but Monday morning everything
changes for all of y'all our lives are
changed forever the phones are going to
start ringing baby they're gonna make
some money off music the next few years
for sure what advice do you have for
them oh listen man enjoy it stop walk
slow smell every rose you can put your
phone down and be present baby this is
the wildest ride of your life and I've
enjoy every second of it and I hope you
do too baby are you stopping and
smelling the Roses oh yes sir and all
kind of flowers I smelled all kinds of
flowers actually we're in Hollywood baby
okay amen amen you know what we uh spoke
with Garth Brooks a few days ago and he
said it was really nice to meet you he
was very sweet I can tell you in three
minutes talking with him you're in love
with a kid he was raised right you
always like for you to meet one of your
items don't talk to me about Garth
Brooks right now I'll flip out y'all
swear to God there's a clip of Garth
Brooks in Vegas
so I got to see Garth Brooks at the ACM
Awards and I was so excited I picked him
up I didn't mean to and I didn't know it
until the cliff went viral so I see him
in Vegas the other night I go to his
show two and a half hour show Insanity
did you see the show no oh it's you got
to go to Vegas for Garth Brooks plus one
right now however yeah I'm watching it I
leave I go backstage I get to see him
again he holds his hands out he goes but
don't hurt me this time big fella he is
the sweetest guy man I grew up with him
with my household it's no greater he is
truly
probably one of the biggest things will
ever happen for me me biggest thing but
light on his feet light on his feet baby
it's it's just as charismatic as you
think he is he is the man it's genuine
Well you aren't you sir genuine and
Charming I gotta say very very nice to
meet you thank you for taking the time
absolutely thank you I love you Garth
there it is